Is that what your issue is? You don't trust us to have the facts.
IS THAT THE PROBLEM, Ken Martin? You don't trust in the facts.
>> You suck at this. Just retire. Just retire. You should
stop doing politics. Be a video game streamer. Be a drama streamer.
Honestly, just go do drama stuff. Don't do this. You're not built
for this. For Hasan, it's like, "So, I see here that you were
saying that like wealthy school girls should be more than the
poor ones, but like this is, you know, I'm sure you stream a
ton and this is like probably out of context and you know, like
yeah, so go ahead. Can you please speak to that?" >> EXCLUDING
THAT WHAT DO YOU TALK WHAT IS THIS What Where are these What
is this analysis? What?
>> DNC Chair Ken Martin grilled on why he won't release
the autopsy. This is, of course, the 2024 DNC autopsy to see
why they lost, right? They did this autopsy. They would normally
release it. They didn't release it at all. Okay? So, people are
like, "Wait, what? What? What did you find that's making you
hesitant to release this?" >> I want to start with the
2024 autopsy, um, which you call an after-action review. When
you won the chairmanship in February of '25,
you criticized the DNC's refusal to release their 2016 autopsy
as exactly what not to do. You said, quote, "Was there any utility
in doing that?" and then promised your 2024 autopsy would be
different. Your exact quote was, "Of course, it will be released."
Why did you change your mind on that? >> Well, look, I
mean, what I said all along, even when I ran for this position,
is that we were going to focus on the things that will help us
win the upcoming election, right? Making sure that we learn the
right lessons that could help inform our victories. And that's
what we've done.
>> Bro, what? >> And it's important for me. Instead
of navel-gazing and looking backwards and, uh, trying to relitigate
2024,
I don't know about you, John, but I don't have a time machine.
I don't think you do. No one does, so we can't change what happened
in '24.
>> Nobody got a time machine. Okay, then why even do an
autopsy? >> So, what changed between August and December?
I understand there are lessons, but those are not the full report.
Why not release the full report? What's in the report that you
wouldn't >> Well, first off, there's no Yeah, there's no
smoking gun in the report, and I know that's that's what everyone's
so eager to learn and I think the smoking gun. Guess what, John?
>> But if there's no But if there's no smoking gun, why
wouldn't you just release it then? >> Be- because we want
to keep the focus on the lessons. >> Is there any way to
read this now other than the report is critical of Kamala Harris
and they think it'll interfere with your 2028 election bid? That
seems like the most obvious reasoning behind this, right? The
report itself would be focused on It would talk about how Kamala
[__] up, and you don't want to release it because
you think it's going to destroy or derail her campaign. >> But
you spent a couple hundred thousand dollars on it, right? >> No,
we did not. >> It was a free report? >> No, we did
not spend a couple hundred thousand dollars on that. >> Dude,
is it going to be that some donor gave you the money to run the
the
And then you're going to say that that wasn't Hey, they they
donated like out of pocket for it. What are you going to >> in
it. We're not paid Uh to do this work. And so, I would just say
that's that's inaccurate, John. So, I appreciate I'm not sure
where you would even get that number. And so, Do you have some
some sort of record that >> The dude, polling in 50 states
to get a bunch of testimonials costs money. What in the [__]
are you talking about? >> shows we spent any money on that?
>> Uh I've seen I've seen reporting that you that you did
spend money on it, yeah, for sure. >> Okay, well, that's
that's inaccurate, okay? The person we asked to do this is an
unpaid advisor to the DNC. And I'm happy to go over what those
lessons are. I'm happy to go over them with uh anyone who wants
to talk about them, John. But what I'm not going to do is release
a report that turns everyone backwards. >> The issue is
you said a report had to be released. You said you were going
to release this 2024 report, obviously, and then you haven't.
Basically, when we all ask what changed here, well, something
changed. You were planning to release it, and then you saw something
that you feel like is either going to hurt elections or more
obviously going to hurt elections for people you like or people
you support.
And so, you don't want to release it. And so, why should I trust
somebody who's so transparently going back on their word with
anything? Why should I trust you at all? You're You've shown
yourself to be completely untrustworthy. Broadly, what I'm concerned
about here is is Destiny seems to be It seems to be really obsessed
with like Hasan and lefties right now, which is fine. It's not
like a It's not a criticism so long as it doesn't affect the
coverage, but he reads so much of the criticisms of like this
cabal that he thinks like me and Hasan are in and and just overall
Hasan's like ascendancy. He reads all of that into the analysis
here and it makes it make no sense at all. Like it's totally
nonsensical through this whole thing. I'm just very interested.
I looked into a little bit of the Jon Favreau stuff.
And just the way this is all framed as this totally
unexpected and crazy attack on Ken
by Jon Favreau. It's to It's just wild. It It makes no sense.
It's completely nonsensical, okay? >> Quick bit of context
for listeners. This all came about because you expressed some
frustration about criticism of the DNC coming from our direction.
So I appreciate you coming on to talk about it directly.
>> Okay. So from the outset of the interview, Jon Favreau
is saying we were criticizing you. We have been criticizing you.
Right? Specifically with regards to this one thing. Thank you
for coming on. Now, that is not what happened with Hasan, right?
Cuz that's going to be the the back and forth. That's going to
be the thing that Destiny's so seething about the whole time
is Ken Martin's getting a harsher interview than Hasan. Well,
Jon Favreau is mad at Ken Martin.
And Ken Martin decided he wanted to come on the show.
Obviously, if Jon Favreau is mad at Ken Martin for some decision
he's made, then he is going to he's going to question him critically
and possibly even aggressively on that bad decision, the thing
he was is about. >> But I do want to press you on some
specific things because I think the stakes are too high not to.
Does that sound fair? >> Sounds great, John. Thank you.
I appreciate it. >> So again, right off the bat, it is
framed as a adversarial interview. This is not going to be a
friendly chat. This is an adversarial interview. You asked to
come on because I have problems with you. That's what we're talking
about. Autopsy, um, which you call an after-action review. When
you won the championship in February of '25, you criticized the
DNC's refusal to release their 2016 autopsy as exactly what not
to do. You said, quote, "Was there any utility in doing that?"
And then promised your 2024 autopsy would be different. Your
exact quote was, "Of
Oh, so this guy does not know how to do an actual challenging
interview. Where the [__] was this when he was talking
to Hasan when he was slurping up Hasan
>> So, I don't know if Destiny was reading chat or not
paying attention, but he didn't hear that it was like basically
agreed to as an adversarial interview before it started. He's
a complete He never He never thinks about this. He doesn't do
any research before he goes into these things. If he'd done any
research, he'd know that Jon Favreau's been about this autopsy
for a very long
But of course, you know what it's about, right? We see exactly
what's happening with the politics here. He's focused on Hasan,
so he can't listen and understand and process. He's just going
to make it about Hasan in any way he can. So, it's
I guess we're going to learn what an actual like challenging
interview is. So, it's not a layup question. It's a challenging
question with a I'm using that term ambush. I think it's fine
in journalism to to ambush people with questions, whatever, right?
To hold them
>> Not an ambush. It was literally this guy, Ken Martin,
who reached out because of the criticism.
So, the framing and you're saying, "Oh, well, it's okay to ambush."
Not an ambush. You're a [__] It was said 30 seconds
ago and you paid no attention. >> But with an ambush quote
to demonstrate an inconsistency that's going to be difficult
to talk his way out of. Okay, so we do know how to do a challenging
interview. Good job. >> Instead of navel-gazing and looking
backwards and uh trying to relitigate 2024, I don't know about
you, John, but I don't have a time machine. I don't think you
do. No one does. >> Real quick, as we're getting into this,
this is Ken Martin. He is the chair of the DNC, okay? If you
guys weren't sure who Ken Martin is, he's the chair of the DNC.
Jon Favreau is a former Obama speechwriter. He's in the He's
in the Obama administration in some fashion, okay? That's him
and a bunch of people who run Pod Save America as a podcast network.
It's a bunch of old Obama staffers who have come together to
create a media apparatus, okay? And explicitly,
Favreau's been about the 2024 campaign, and he's been explicitly
like frustrated with no basic Nobody's like said the exact mistakes.
That that's what this is all about, right? That's what this whole
thing has been about is he's been He's been commenting on it
for months. And he's not like a leftist, he's not a populist.
He is an Obama staffer. He is like a neoliberal at heart. That's
who he is. Are we going to continue doing like a you know, like
a somewhat conversational interview and we're going to go to
the next thing or is this going to be like a hostile, aggressive
interview and he's going to tell me to answer it, bring back
up the quote again and force me to answer it? Let's find out.
Well, it's obviously going to be that he confronts him and keeps
bringing it up because that was the point if you'd been listening
for the first like 90 seconds of the interview. That was the
point of the interview was to get this question answered. That
is Specifically, Ken Martin wanted to come on because John has
been upset about this. John's been commenting on this for a while,
this specific autopsy report. He wants the autopsy. He's wanted
the autopsy. And when Ken Martin said he wasn't going to release
the autopsy, John went live the next podcast and complained about
it directly.
That's what it's always been about. Hey, release this autopsy.
Realistically, what I think this is, it has nothing to do with
populism, has nothing to do with lefties, has nothing to do with
Hasan, okay? Get Hasan out of your head. This is an Obama staffer
who, going back like a decade, there has been a rivalry since
Obama refused to coronate, as so to speak, Biden to follow him
up. Since Obama let Hillary run after after him, okay? Gave the
nod to Hillary over Biden. There has been a rivalry between Biden
staffers and Obama staffers. This has been going on for now I
it's more than a decade at this point, okay?
Favreau is a part of that. Favreau is because something happened
in 2024 that led to this old demented
Joe Biden, who we love. We love sleepy Joe. But he was demented.
He had some problems, okay?
Something happened that they let this guy run again.
And Jon Favreau, I believe, is very very annoyed about this and
the fact that Kamala Harris was coronated.
Right? And he thinks those things are going to be in the report.
And he's got his own connections, his own political like career,
his own political aspirations that he's trying to get confirmation
that these are the things that went wrong. So he knows how to
move forward in the future. He knows how to help the DNC. And
by the way, there's other conversations he's had with donors
and [__] He references them in here
people don't trust that this party won't [__] up
this way again. And people don't want to waste their money. Okay?
I haven't watched this yet, so I have no idea. Maybe they'll
just go on, I don't know. But on this show, in August, you told
me this about releasing the review, quote, we >> God damn,
we're in hostile interview >> So we've already gotten very
hyperbolic about it being hostile.
In fact, if you listen to John there instead of instead of freaking
out, instead of spazzing, because you are mad that you think
like this is him defending Hassan somehow, instead of spazzing,
you could listen. He says, "Well, back on the show in August,
you told me that you were going to release this. Like you you
told me that directly."
Well, it sounds like John got told something and he's going,
"Hey, what what gives?
You you like lied to me. You like actually just straight-up lied
to me. What the So when Ken Martin comes on here and they've
talked about it, they've talked about this autopsy
probably several times, at least once
What did anybody think was going to
Ken Martin had to have known that he couldn't just dodge the
question entirely, right? He had to have known
Right. So, they know they do know how to do it. Okay. Woo. Have
to do it to give people who invested so much time, energy, and
money a sense of what happened and why we lost. Correct? Especially
why we lost. So, what changed between August and December? I
understand there are lessons, but those are not the full report.
Why not release the full report? So, December is when Ken announces
that he's not going to release the report, okay?
Jon was very annoyed about that. Let me pull the segment from
his stream. It says, "4 months ago, December 2025." >> Well,
unfortunately, not all Democrats deserve praise this week, Dan.
Uh we've talked before about the DNC's much-anticipated 2024
postmortem, also known as an autopsy unless you're talking to
DNC chair Ken Martin, who calls it a quote after-action report.
Martin told reporters after he won the DNC election back in February
that he would make the final report public. And he even criticized
the party then for not releasing the 2016
postmortem as an example of why he was going to release the 2024
postmortem if he won the election, which he did.
And here he is talking to me about the importance of the report
back in August. >> We're finishing our after-action review
to really dig into this to give people a sense who invested so
much time, energy, and money what happened and why we lost. There
are no sacred cows. What we're looking at right now is everything.
>> There's no There are no sacred cows. That's it. If we
find out that there's like major reasons, major contributing
factors, we will not leave those out. Jon Lovett believes that
a major two major contributing factors happened. These are the
things he's looking for here, okay? Jon Favreau What Jon Favreau
wants, he wants to know that it was Biden covering stuff up and
that that that really them over. He wants to know how much. And
he wants to know whether or not having a closed or not having
a primary, like an open convention, the Democrats over. That's
what he wants to know, because he believes, and those are both
decisions Obama was on the same side as him on, right? Obama
wanted an open primary. Obama did not want Kamala Harris coordinated.
He felt like she was going to lose.
That's what Jon's looking for, in my opinion. John was waiting
on this. He had basically stuff lined up based on the outcome
of it, and now it's all frozen because he's waiting for the actual
outcome, and and it's not been released, okay? >> No sacred
cows, Dan.
Well, on Thursday, the DNC announced that just kidding,
they won't be releasing the report after all. Martin said, quote,
"Here's our North Star. Does this help us win? If the answer
is no, it's a distraction from the core
>> So, that's the exact polar opposite of no sacred cows.
When you say no sacred cows, it's saying, "Even if it hurts,
even if it's going to be like frustrating to put out there, we'll
put it out there for the sake of transparency,
right?"
And then, they decided to change up. They decided to switch up
and go, "Oh, well, actually, I don't know if that's a good lesson
for us to take away."
Jon Favreau thinks He thinks the Biden team's incompetent. He
thinks a lot of these DNC people are incompetent. It is not outside
the norm to think Ken Martin is incompetent within DNC circles.
And by the way, the people who really think he's incompetent
are actually like the more neoliberal business wing types.
Okay? It's not lefties. It's not grassroots organizers. It's
not populists.
This guy represents the business interests, the business wing
of the party, the Obama wing of the party, the big money donors.
That's who this guy represents.
what he's interested in. That's what he's trying to figure out.
And that's, by the way, who Ken Martin has no interest in talking
to and has essentially alienated in a lot of ways.
So, Jon Favreau is mad because they're not getting big money
donors cutting huge checks to get them all the things they need,
all the ad spend they need. They are in debt as a party or they
were at least as of the last I think financial filing. And there's
no reason for them to be. >> But instead the navel-gazing
and focusing backwards actually takes us backwards. We're 189
days from this election, John. What we don't need to be focused
on >> agree. I don't know why they wouldn't just release
it unless like is it like is there something about how they should
have been like harsher on Israel so they feel stupid or something
or don't want to give credit to some political or like I don't
know why you wouldn't release it. I I can't I don't know why.
Like I don't know why. I have no idea why. And he said it already
but it's disgusting because these people can do tough interviews
and fact is clearly a hustle. Yeah. And to be clear, I appreciate
this. I think we should be able to do these types of interviews.
I think this is good journalism. But it only ever happens against
the center left. Only. Always. Only and always against the center
left. Look, where the [__] was any of this with Hasan?
So Hasan, I see here that you said you wanted to that every Zionist
inbred is a pig. Um and like I don't >> He totally hyperbolizes
what Hasan said, I guess.
Yeah, totally makes up all of the stuff. We're talking about
Hasan. >> It's probably like like out of context, right?
So can you explain this, Hasan? >> Yeah. Wink wink. Oh
yeah. Like as a joke. Yeah, so uh >> So like this has nothing
to do with Hasan and he's just he's mad that Jon Favreau wasn't
harsh on Hasan. But again, if you were watching the beginning
of this interview where Jon Favreau literally says, "Oh, you
you asked you reached out to us because we had criticism so you
came on to discuss that criticism." It was set up as an adversarial
interview from the >> And we're going to continue to put
those lessons we've learned into action and I hope others will
start to do the same. >> Yeah, I'm just trying to figure
out because it doesn't it certainly doesn't seem like anyone's
looking for one single silver bullet because it's a two >> 200
page >> What a Why? >> And he's a liar. I respect
it. I respect that he's a snake liar. You're acting like a whole
contingent right now of the far left movement online isn't looking
for one silver Jew coded bullet from this report. Are you like
how slimy? Okay, dude.
>> Yeah, he doesn't care because for real for real Democrat
operatives who operate in the real world, they don't care about
online communists.
They don't give a
So, it's cool that you are worried about Israel still making
this about Israel
That's not what Jon Favreau's worried about right now at all.
He doesn't care. It's It's so funny.
Oh, man. It's so funny just watching him miss and miss and miss.
That's not what he's worried about. Geez, dude. Hunter was so
correct. He was so We need a We need a a Biden-Harris ticket
or a Biden-Clinton ticket. Oh, my god. We need a Hunter-Biden
Hillary-Clinton
Kamala-Harris They need to be a thrupple, okay? Actually, uh-huh.
What I just said. Is Harris Kamala Harris Is she married? She's
like kids or whatever, right? I don't give a Hunter needs to
marry one of them, Hillary or Kamala. First lady and then the
other can be VP. That's what we need. Or Hunter Biden can be
first man or whatever. We haven't had one of those yet, right?
And Kamala or Clinton can run. That's what we need. >> If
people believe there's something there's some sort of magic silver
bullet in there that's going to solve all of our ills at the
Democratic Party.
And I I I I understand >> I don't think I don't think there's
going to be a magic silver bullet, though. Who Who thinks that?
No one thinks it's That's a such a No one thinks there's a magic
silver bullet. It's a 200-page report you interview people in
50 states. You spent a lot of donor money on it. I think people
are probably wondering like >> We didn't spend a lot of
donor money on that. And And that's just inaccurate. I used to
spend a couple hundred thousand dollars on it, right? >> No,
we did not. >> It was a free report?
>> We did not spend a couple hundred thousand dollars on
that. So, I appreciate I'm not sure where you would even get
that number. And so, did you have some some sort of record that
shows we spent any money on that?
>> Oh, sh
How do you get fooled by that? Like, sorry, that's such a stupid
answer that Jon Favreau is dumbfounded, right? You got a report
where you had hundreds of interviews
from 50 different states. All of this stuff was coordinated,
all of it was with a purpose.
Oh, that cost us nothing, actually.
What? You You had this massive undertaking, it cost you nothing?
I This is bizarre.
Uh why is Destiny even being so adversarial to Jon? Because he
thinks Jon is in the Hasan [__] cabal. And he's totally
broken his brain over >> It was an exhaustive um exercise
to really get at what are those key lessons. And I want to be
very clear, there's nothing that changed from what I said on
the campaign trail to now, which is we >> on the When you
were on the campaign trail and you talked about definitely releasing
an autopsy and criticized the DNC for not releasing >> Damn,
Destiny again on the quote. >> an autopsy in 2016. In your
mind In your mind you thought I'm going to do one but only release
certain lessons and not the full report. >> No, what I
said at the time is exactly what I've been saying now, which
is we have to focus on the things that help us win the future
elections. >> The issue that the DNC's having right now
is a lack of trust.
How is this fixing that problem? By the way, every single Democrat
think tank, every single Democrat advisor, every single Democrat
politician, every single Democrat voter knows this. That trust
is at an all-time low. You're not trusted. Do you know how you
build trust? Transparency. You show some transparency, you say,
"Here's Here's like our output that we had from this, and here's
the lessons we want to take away." And then you let some people
argue over, "Hey, maybe there's some other lessons, or maybe
some of these lessons are more important than others."
When you just say, "No, take the lessons and don't look at any
of the underlying
that's terrifying for people who don't trust you already. >> That's
what I'm saying. NBC News said that before Easter, about a month
ago, you told DNC officers on a call to expect an executive summary
in short order. Officers on that call told NBC they still haven't
received one. You told that a North Carolina DNC member who was
drafting a resolution to force the report's release that summary
was forthcoming, and he backed off based on that promise. >> So,
not only did Ken lie to everybody and then lie to John,
Ken has also been lying to DNC members, and basically one DNC
member was apparently drafting a an internal resolution to force
the the release of the report, and Ken said, "No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, we're releasing an executive summary,
right?"
and now he's on this interview, and when John asked, "Well, you're
going to release the executive summary then?" Ken said, "Well,
we've been releasing it." So, no, the answer there is no. You
read between the lines, the answer is no, we're not releasing
anything, bro. So, he got somebody not to file a resolute or
I guess put a resolution together that was going to force it
or try to force the release of the report,
and he got somebody to back off of doing that. If you were paying
attention and not playing video games because you have no interest
in politics and you're only doing this spitefully because you
built something up there and now you have no interest anymore,
you just want to play video game. Right? If If you're
this is really bad. This guy is This guy is being a complete
[__] >> You're proving the point that I think
many folks I think are frustrated in this party, which is people
want to turn backwards to relitigate the 2024 election. They're
pointing fingers, they're placing blame to to to >> But don't
you want to learn lessons like you said? >> Well, listen,
to win elections if they want to win elections, I'm happy to
share what we learn in in the way of the lessons on why we lost.
>> I and I I can tell you exactly what this is, right?
Do you want me to tell you what this is? There cuz I know people
talked about this during 2024.
A bunch of people gave millions and millions and millions of
dollars to the Biden campaign.
Then he had a his brain melted out of his ears on live TV. So,
these people got convinced, "Hey, you should donate. This guy's
This guy's sharp as a tack. This guy can do anything. This guy
is the best He's the strongest he's ever been." Okay?
Gave millions, tens of billions. I'm sure some donors gave up
to hundreds of millions. I'm not sure how many would have given
that much, but some people gave a lot of money, right?
And then this guy's brain melted out of his ears. And what I
would want to know, if I gave 10 million or 50 million dollars,
I'm a billionaire, I give 50 million dollars this campaign, right?
In some way, I go to all the states, I put in it the maximum,
I max out everywhere,
What I'm going to want to know is what is responsible for that
happening? And unless they're gone, I'm not giving you money
again. [__] you. >> Longtime Democratic strategist
who's run Florida for the party >> told the Washington
Examiner that there's a quote financial penalty specifically
tied to burying the autopsy because donors want a clear accounting
before re-committing. The DNC is entering April with negative
net cash on >> There we go.
>> standard of does this help us win, is it possible that
the autopsy decision is actually costing you the money you need
to win?
just factually
John has spoken to donors
who believe that this autopsy decision is going to prevent who
are saying, "I'm not giving any money until I see that
He knows people who have said this, >> John. And I'm sure
you follow the campaign finance reports like I do. We raised
$105 million in 2025. A record amount of money for >> The
DNC did or like all the Democratic Party or >> The first
year >> You don't have you're not you don't you're not
have negative cash on hand right now? You don't you don't have
debt that's made it negative cash on hand? >> we also we
do have debt, John, and
>> So this is John referencing reporting about how the
DNC's getting massively out-fundraised by the RNC
and how the total resources on hand for the DNC is much lower
than the RNC. But what Ken's saying is, "No, but that's intended.
Like we're not we're not meaning to have cash on hand. We are
taking the money as we get it, we're spending it immediately
because we have a plan for how we want to do this." Which is
okay. That's fine. And but I think a lot of people who are aligned
with John see this as total >> But to suggest that we're
not raising money is inaccurate. We raised $32 million We raised
$32 million in the first quarter. But what we're doing that's
a little different, John, is we're spending it. We're raising
it and we're spending it because one of the lessons we learned
>> You're spending more than you have. I mean, you guys
have 13.9 million cash on hand, right? I'm going to read the
report. 13.9 million cash on hand, 18.3 million in debt. So,
that's roughly negative $4.4 million. And I know it's a tough
environment for the party out of power, but the DSCC and the
DS- Triple C and the Senate candidates have plenty of money.
They're all doing great. So, it seems like this is a this is
an issue unique to the DNC.
>> I I don't even know if it's I don't know if that's good
or bad, but I do know that trying to evaluate the success of
some project based on whether or not they have cash on hand or
in debt is probably one of the dumbest things I've ever seen
in my entire life. That doesn't really tell you much of anything.
I like are they
I like I don't know what Ken is thinking or why he hasn't brought
this up, but I mean like regardless of your feeling on Ken Martin
of the DNC or whatever else, the Democratic Party
and the and I mean like Ken and I think the DNC could take some
credit for this, right? Has completely annihilated the Republicans
in like special elections and over the past >> It's the
It's the same thing. It's the same complacency again. Guys, we're
winning right now. Why Why do we change anything? We're winning
right now.
I'm I'm positive that if Ken Martin took personally every single
dollar, turned it into cash, put it on a pallet, and set it on
fire,
you would not be able to tell the difference in the polls in
the elections following, right? In the elections following the
2025 or sorry, 2024 presidential election and with everything
Donald Trump's done, you wouldn't even be able to tell the the
difference in these special elections. Of course, Republicans
are losing. They've literally just been hitting people in the
streets, right? Like ISIS going crazy, Donald Trump's doing the
most corruption imaginable. Of course, they're unpopular. Now,
I don't think Ken's doing that. Ken could have a strategy, but
it's like, dude, you cannot say, "Well, we're winning, so it's
fine. We're winning, so it's fine." You sound stupid. >> Guess
what I did for 14 years in a very purple state? Win, John. And
I'm just telling you right now. I think you and others who continue
to bet against the DNC, keep betting. Because That's what Here's
THE THING. TRUE. UH REALITY, JOHN, we're winning. And we're winning
because I'm I'm >> are making it up. I mean, you obviously
there's a difference between off-year elections and mid-term
elections and what it's going to take to build the kind of infrastructure
>> I'm sorry. What Do you think we're gearing up to lose
the midterms? I mean, what is that what you want to bank your
current hostility on? That the midterms are not going to go well
for the Democrats? Or what? >> We need to win in 2028,
right? I mean, I I just think that that's that's it.
>> I don't I don't think that's what he's saying. I do
think it's going to be about 2028.
He's He's saying that these ones don't really indicate going
forward. Un- Unfortunately, if he wanted to bank on the midterms,
like Donald Trump has destroyed the American economy, gas is
soaring in price. Like, it's it's like totally over for them
in the midterms. All right, everybody hates Trump right But again,
that's nothing to do with the >> You talked about investing
in state parties. The headline number is $20,000 a month per
state. My understanding is that also includes like the Democratic
Party of Guam and the Party of the Northern Mariana Islands,
who get the basically the same check as Pennsylvania, Wisconsin,
and North Carolina. I get that every state and territory has
DNC members.
>> What the [__] is he even arguing right This
is about Ken Martin starting a program where he doubled the amount
sent by the DNC to state parties, and that I guess John here
seems to be arguing, oh, every month. And John here seems to
be arguing that like, do you really want to send the same check
to Guam that you sent to Pennsylvania? That seems kind of
Right? That seems kind of dumb. That's what he's arguing. Is
that even hard to follow? Hey, why are you spending the same
amount in Guam as you are in Pennsylvania? Did you know Guam
doesn't have a senator? Did you know Guam doesn't even Well,
does Guam even have house seats? I know they get presidential
votes.
They go somewhere.
But do they even have a house member?
I don't think they do, do they? Puerto Rico doesn't. There's
no way Guam does, right? No, they don't. They don't. In any case,
that's the argument he's making. Hey, isn't it really dumb to
send the same amount of money to both of these places? Very easy
to understand argument. >> What This is like the I just
wanted to say, okay, and listen, it's not even necessarily bad
asking these questions, but we are we are so in the weeds on
financials for the DNC, right? Like, this is this is a crazy
in-depth interview. Like, we need to talk about the DNC. Yeah,
sure. Well, we you know, we've had historic outperformance in
races and everything else. You guys are in debt. Um yeah, we
you know, we raised a historic amount of money, we also spent
a historic amount of money, but we've had historic performance
uh >> Was it really a historic amount of money? And so,
it wasn't a historic amount of money. It was the best that's
happened for a DNC chair the first year they've come in, which
is like, okay, I understand that a little bit. You would think
with the least popular Republican administration ever, that's
a given, that's automatic.
And I think since then, since 2025, I do believe they've started
to lag.
from what I read in the Matt Yglesias article, because Ken Martin
is not very good at talking to donors, that he is prickly, he
is like actually offending these people, and they are holding
back their money.
And that's essentially what's like killing what It's bad. It's
a very bad situation, and there are people who are very informed
in Dem circles who are go who are ringing an alarm bell already,
going, "This guy is actually really up. Hello, hello. This guy's
really up right now. Everybody get in."
>> But also, there's no way to remove a DNC chair, it seems
like, so. >> Uh, gains in uh all of the seats we've been
running in. Okay, but have you considered the fact that you're
sending about $100,000 to places like Guam and other US territories
where we don't actually have federal voters or like
Holy sh We're like we're in there. Like, are we going to criticize
how we're filing our taxes next, or Jesus? It's like on a quick
thing, and I can play this out all day, right? And I can tell
you I can already see how like this all develops. I'm seeing
the matrix more for all these media cycles, okay?
If this was on Fox News, right, he would be getting a slap interview
by Sean Hannity, and every single talking point that he's giving
right now, all of these would be repeated at >> This is
totally worthless analysis, given that Jon Favreau had issues
with Ken Martin not releasing the report, stated as much, and
Ken reached out to him to talk about the issues John had.
obviously, if you're like even in Republican media, if a if a
pundit has a major disagreement with you, they have a major problem
with you, and you reach out to talk to them, and say, "Hey, I'll
come on to talk about this." They're going to have that conversation
aggressively. Especially if you continue to gaslight them in
that conversation.
Right? It really doesn't matter It seems to not matter at all
here, right?
All right, sorry. It seems to not matter at all whether
what like how this would be handled on Fox. Cuz this isn't a
neutral interview. It was never meant to be a neutral interview.
It was never about being a neutral interview. Ken reached out
to John
from the start. Saying, "Hey, we need to talk about this." >> Which
is extra sad cuz I'm pretty sure Ken Martin I think he's been
factually correct in everything that he's saying and Republicans
aren't. They usually >> Mhm. Ken Martin is being very,
very weaselly in the things he's saying, >> lefties don't.
They just lie. And I I wonder if we would have I I I wonder how
many people
This was a day ago. I wonder how many slopulist YouTube channels
reviewed this And it's the mega effect. They see it as >> It's
so funny. He does He's done this a couple times now. He's the
person engaging in like a form of populism, right? He's consistently
like bringing up the specter of Hasan to get people on board
with agreeing with Democrats against all logic, all reason, all
factual basis. He's using people's emotions and popular sentiment
against Hasan to try to convince his audience, "You should You
should dislike this. You should be upset You shouldn't be upset
about this. You should actually be upset at John Favreau for
doing this interview, right?" That's what's going on here. It's
so funny that he's like, "Oh, these slopulists, these lu- Bro,
your narrative is
You suck at this. Just retire.
Just retire. You should stop doing politics. Be a video game
streamer. Be a drama streamer. Honestly, just go do drama stuff.
Don't do this. You're not built for this >> was a hostile
interview, so he's the enemy. John is their team. And so, I wonder
if like Kukulinski, Crystal Ball,
uh Majority Report, I don't know if Hasan watched it. All >> Did
he just say John is his John is their team. >> So, he's
the enemy. John is their team. And so, I I if like Kukulinski,
Crystal
uh Majority Report, I don't know if Hasan watched it. All the
fire alarm channels will watch this and just shred this guy to
pieces and then fully back up what John is saying. Maybe, but
I don't know. Well, I'll go look for some afterwards. I mean
I think basically everybody, and this is another thing, this
is the the neoliberal gaslighting effect,
You shouldn't be mad at this guy for making multiple promises
and breaking them. You should be mad at this guy for asking why
this guy lied. Be mad at this guy for for asking why he was lied
to. That's who you should be mad about. Be mad at that.
Amazing stuff. Hold on a second. I I'm being told I should check
out this Z to the Hill video. >> Ken Martin should step
down as DNC >> By the way, I think this is where they're
going with this. I think there is no way to get rid of Ken Martin
and they need him to step down as DNC chair. So, it's very funny
Dusty's talking about the Yeah, Dusty's talking about the
the slopulists. Oh, no. Hold on. Can we Can we make those line
up? This was a day ago. >> I wonder how many slopulist
YouTube channels reviewed this talk. And it's the mega effect.
They see it as a hostile interview, so he's the enemy. John is
their team. And so, I wonder if like Kukulinski, Crystal Ball,
uh Majority Report, I don't know if Hasan watched it. All the
fire alarm channels will watch this and just shred this guy to
pieces and then fully back up what John is saying. Maybe, but
>> Ken Martin should step down as DNC chair and people
inside the party are starting to say it. So, let's talk about
it. Really quick to catch you up. So, a couple of days ago Ken
Martin went on the Pod Save America podcast. And on that podcast,
they were questioning why he would not release the 2024 autopsy
report. If you don't know what that is, it's essentially a report
that says why we lost the 2024 election. And it's important to
note that Ken Martin ran his race saying that he was going to
release this report. That is literally what he campaigned on.
>> It's cool. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. So, yes, it seems
like even Z understands that probably the bad thing here is the
lying. Just obviously completely lying about this is the bad
thing to do. >> Within the DNC, there is a lot of tension
over this because obviously in order for us to win elections,
we need to know what went wrong. This is not the leadership that
we need right now in the Democratic Party. We need people that
are aggressive about giving us answers so that way we can move
forward and we can build the infrastructure we need to win future
elections. >> Yes, thank you, Z. This is actually maybe
the best video she's done. Damn. So true. So obviously true.
Oh, here we go. Oh, here it is. I wondered how long it would
take for us to get here. Destiny Peace Go hated this guy. Destiny,
don't you know Peace Go's like a communist slopulist YouTuber?
Peace Go's the most lived up human being on planet Earth. And
everybody in DGG is like, "He's a communist populist.
He's a communist populist shill. This lawyer." >> When
was the last time Trump came on and they're like, "Mr. President,
I'm sorry I'm being so harsh on you, but we need to win. We need
to win, Mr. President. That's why I'm being so
>> 60 Minutes literally read a quote from the guy calling
him like a
uh from the shooter who called him a to his face. >> It
is it concerns me that I see two things. One, this uh autopsy
which you campaigned on releasing and and I know you're releasing
lessons, but are hiding still plenty of the details in the autopsy
and I just can't figure out what details that are in there that
you don't want out there because you don't trust people with
because they're going to I guess argue about them. Damn. Because
it feels like we >> Also, remember the difference between
layup questions for Hasan versus like challenging questions um
for this guy, right? For Hasan, it's like, "So, I see here that
you were saying that like, you know, wealthy wealthy school girls
should be more than the poor ones, but like this is, you know,
I'm sure you stream a ton and this is like probably out of context
and you know, like yeah. So, go ahead. Can you please speak to
that? Like, can you please speak to that?" Meanwhile, for Ken
Martin, who has had a
It's like it's such an interesting
It's so disconnected from Hasan.
And that's all he can see. And it prevents him from being able
to like internalize, intellectualize anything else going on here.
like it's it's there's so much going on here that has nothing
to do with Hasan. But he just keeps talking about Hasan over
and over again. Cuz Hasan had a a general interview, right?
This was never set up. This interview with Ken Martin was never
set up to be general interview. >> Um I noticed so you
haven't released this list. Is it because you're terrified of
people getting a little bit of the goddamn truth? Hasan, what
your issue is? You don't trust us to have the facts. Is that
the problem, Ken Martin? You don't trust us with the facts. It's
like Jesus Christ. >> are hiding still plenty of the details
in the autopsy. I just can't figure out what details that are
in there that you don't want out there because you don't trust
people with because they're going to I guess argue about them.
Because it feels like we really need a robust discussion about
where the party's headed. Not just pundits like me, but the state
party chairs and the DNC committee members who are asking you
to release it. >> They're asking you to release it. >> I
know you want to keep focusing on that and that's fine. >> Well,
I think and I do think that that >> And the fundraising
isn't going well either. So, I feel like that's >> The
fundraising is going well after he said they've raised more money
in a year than they have in any previous year ever? You're basing
it on the fact that their fundraising was poor because they have
debt? Because they >> That's not true. If he thought about
that for 2 seconds, he'd know that wasn't true.
You think they're raising more in this in 2026 even in the midterms
than they would for a presidential election? Like come on, man.
Just use your brain for 2 seconds. It was they raised more in
the first year for a new DNC chair than they ever have before.
That was the line. >> They spent more money?
>> This is completely inaccurate, John. You had a great
>> I'm at a huge >> I'm at a huge advantage here.
I'll be real. I'm at a huge advantage, okay? Cuz I'm not playing
video games and barely engaging with the material. So, I'm it's
like I'm able to use my actual brain to understand and not just
operate off of my seething hatred for Hasan. I just get to I
get to watch, I get to internalize, I understand. It's like a
crazy concept. I know it's it's very rare. It's like unheard
of.
But you just watch the actual content and engage with it, understand
it, and
boost good content in turn instead of just being a loser? I don't
know. >> You had a first You had a great first year in
2025. >> And we've had a great first quarter. $32 million
we raised in the first quarter. We raised $4 million in March
than Tom Perez did in 2018. We have We have We have 50%.
>> EXCLUDING THAT WHAT ARE YOU TALKING WHAT IS THIS WHAT
WHERE ARE THESE WHAT is this analysis? What?
This is the equivalent to like huh I noticed that Facebook, I
think they lost money. You guys actually spent more than you
made last year, so I just want to say in terms of in terms of
earners, not to brag, but I made more money than Facebook last
So, like Yeah, it is a disagreement in the way they're handling
this, right? John thinks that you should be building up a war
chest for the midterm elections. You're not building up a war
chest right now. What you're doing is you're 6 months out, I
think, from the midterms, right? Midterms would be November of
You're 6 months out from the midterms, and you are in debt.
Unheard of. Totally unheard of in the history of politics, basically.
And John's very scared that you're headed for like a a historic
crash despite like winning massively, despite being way out ahead
in terms of popularity, or at least not at anywhere near as underwater
as the Republicans. He's worried that you could actually really
underperform in a way you would never expect because you're in
debt 6 months before the election. >> Technically speaking,
okay, I made more money than Facebook. They were like negative
like 42 billion. I made more money than like What the kind of
analysis is this? Holy >> There's plenty of reports about
this. I talked to plenty people about this that that a lot of
big donors still have not come off the sidelines. Part of the
reason is that there's a trust issue >> Like What are we
What are we complaining about here? There are big donors that
haven't come off the sidelines. So, the issue is what? Raising
money? Because it sounds like they've had historic fundraising
years, and this is a historic fundraising quarter. So, what what
I don't understand. He needs to do something different for the
donors. >> Hey, they're I don't maybe, but I don't think
so. I don't think there's any way they're getting out-raised
that significantly by Republicans and breaking all of the records.
Is there? Cuz Cuz they are, isn't that also in and of itself
Like completely terrifying?
You've lost You've lost fundraising to every single Republican
every quarter to
But you're breaking records? How would How'd that happen? >> donors
even though he raised more money than they've ever raised in
the history of all the DNCs. I don't understand what the What
is the argument here? Also, I thought we hated donors. >> Partly
on the autopsy. >> Yeah, I'm just not seeing that jet.
>> Yeah, see also I hate I thought we hated donors. That's
Destiny once again having Hassan's getting his ear instead of
listening or paying attention or knowing who Jon Favreau is or
who this guy is. Right? In fact, the Bernie approach to fundraising
is far more Ken Martin than it is Jon Favreau. Jon Jon Favreau
is about big money. He wants big money donors getting their money
in everybody's pocket. That's what Jon Favreau wants. >> Well,
guys, I want to make sure you guys have enough money and I know
there's, you know, fun >> What is your only concern? Oh
my god. Oh my god. >> is that you're being RNC raised nearly
double than you guys. So I want to make sure you have enough
money and, you know, the DSCC and the DCCC and everyone else
in the Senate committees are raising a whole bunch of money and
matching Republicans. So I just want to make sure you guys have
the money. >> This is the big deal is basically a bunch
of Dem insiders are looking at the the fundraising numbers and
they're going, "Holy [__] How in the world are we
like so How in the world are these Republicans like breaking
every law? They're the most corrupt
most evil administration this country's ever had like unambiguously
more or less, right? Unambiguously.
How are we not raising record amounts? How are we And you They're
not. They're really not, okay? He said it's a record amount for
a first year for any new chair, and that's true, I guess. I'm
not sure who he could compare it against or how good the comparables
are.
But man, you need to You should have so much money coming in.
There should be so many Americans ready to open their
>> as well. They're not matching Republicans. Every Every
Republican committee out-raised their counterpart. The RNC not
by double is you guys and RNC, but Well, but you were just completely
and totally factually wrong before though, right? Weren't you
just Didn't you just get completely gapped here by that comment
that he just know >> I what? What is he talking about?
What? What?
this is like one of the things cuz I always get rattled when
I [__] up or somebody says something totally contradicts
what I say cuz then I have to think like is this person lying
to me or was I actually completely wrong here? I got to think
the research I did I got to think what research names are they
using a talking point, right? But these guys, the shameless people,
they just steamroll right on through.
But okay. >> Republicans I just want to make sure you guys
have the money as well. There's not matching Republicans everywhere
>> Every Republican committee out raised their counterpart.
The RNC out raised by double you guys in RNC but I hear you they
didn't out raise us by double either. We raised 32 million dollars
>> Okay, who's in red on that? >> Mr. They're 56
million or 54 million >> I'm going I'm going by the March
numbers which is 11 to 21 but I hear you. I hear >> Oh,
they're just going by different
And by the way, what was it? Hold on. What did he say? >> It's
by double either. We raised 32 million dollars >> Okay,
who's in red on that? >> 32 56 million or 54 32 to 54.
Okay, so that's
I mean it's not it's not double but it's you know, 1.75
1.8 somewhere in there. And then it was double in March.
>> I'm going I'm going by the March numbers which is 11
to 21 but I hear you. I hear you. All right. Even 11 to 21 is
not technically double but March for one month? You're cherry-picking
a single month? Is that what we're It's not technically double.
So he wasn't wrong. So he wasn't
Like it's it's so funny.
But weren't you totally blown out? Like obviously every human
being who watches this interview understands the lie that happened
and they're annoyed about it. And as he's like trying to
you said double but actually it was 11 versus 21 so you're wrong.
You're like totally wrong and gapped.
Serious political serious political analyst by the way that people
take seriously. They want to go do like canvassing with this
guy. Total [__] Complete [__] All right.
Embarrassing fellow.